after a few alterations the costume is
perfect err hon I says the garment has
to fit just right
as a belly dancer he spends lots of time
at tailors and cloth merchants in his
home city Istanbul in Istanbul you've
got unlimited possibilities there's an
abundance of all kinds of accessories
and fabrics I designed this garment
himself he's going to perform in it for
the first time later in the evening the
historic quarter of Istanbul on the
Golden Horn
this is where Han aya dances regularly
at venues male belly dancers have long
been a tradition in Turkey they emerged
during the Ottoman Empire because women
dancers were only allowed to perform for
women
although the male performers were
reputed to be homosexual they were
widely appreciated but over time women
replaced men on the stage for decades
male dancers could only perform at
private parties or in nightclubs
frequented by gay men still look askance
at male belly dancers in a conservative
society like Turkey's that's got a great
deal to do with prejudice my sexual
orientation is my private business I'm
not interested in the opinions of others
what's important is that my mother has
always supported me discovered my love
of dance and music as a child Aaron came
to fame after starring in a film called
Xena dancer the story of a love affair
between two men also triggered a
renaissance of the old dance form the
filmmakers clearly see male belly dance
as a homosexual domain it's return is an
expression of a new confidence within
turkeys gay community gays and lesbians
were at the forefront of the gezi
protests two years ago
they carried the rainbow flag and were
embraced by everyone the rain wolf lager
get hardens after skinny Republican hot
Co arms on the other hand society is
becoming more conservative at the same
time there are more and more people who
want to express what and who they are
they're making some last preparations
before he takes the stage the women
dancers are wowed by Aaron eyes new
outfit they say the men are no threat to
women's dance but swinging male hips are
a social trend right now it's not United
some young turks are becoming more
interested in their country's history in
tradition they're reflecting on our own
dance traditions male belly dancing
profits from this nostalgic trend I
nevertheless dreams of making a career
abroad he's already appeared several
times at dance festivals in Western
Europe you can earn more money there as
well the most lucrative performances are
still at private parties for example
birthdays and weddings there are lots of
tips
the performance at the Cabaret starts
with a female belly dancer the tourists
in the audience have seen this kind of
thing before err hon I is next and the
audience is fascinated by more than just
his glittering new costume
the guests from abroad remain on after
the show their opinions vary
I think ladies can get I think they get
they would be more appreciated until I
catch shows that Turkey has some very
different colorful sides that was
beautiful
ere Han I is planning his own solo show
he also wants to teach other men how to
dance to ensure that the old tradition
remains a part of modern Turkey